the king of all media Howard Stern now
you look at here Howard I'm tired of
fighting with you man why do you always
have to fight with me why because you
think I'm the low lying fruit Wendy
Williams and Howard Stern can't seem to
get on the same page when it comes to
supporting one another less than a year
after the two radio legends ended a
nasty Feud wendy is firing back at the
former America's Got Talent judge for a
shady comment he made about her career
on Monday Howard mentioned the daytime
talk show host on his Sirius XM show as
he was talking about the national radio
Hall of Fame which he was inducted in
2012 a year after Wendy Howard said
quote no offense to Wendy Williams but
they put Wendy Williams in before me
Wendy did not let that comment slide
during the hot topics portion of her
show on Tuesday she had some choice
words for Howard before me you know what
I'm saying yeah he was he was in before
I was personally and professionally I
admire you Howard Stern but and they
weren't long for that but don't hate on
me because I got in before you the
talk-show host didn't go without
throwing a bit of shade in there she
explained that the only reason she got
into the Hall of Fame for Howard is
because she had a new talk show
something Howard has yet to achieve
flashbacks May of 2019 when their beef
was at an all-time high the two radio
stars got into a heated exchange after
Wendy said that Hollywood changed Howard
Howard is so Hollywood right now that
this book is gonna be this is what you
command Howard I love you but since
you've gone Hollywood everything that
you say is so predictable to say that
Howard didn't take Wendy's comments
lightly is an understatement worry about
your husband not me both
Shikha heart our boat go Howard later
apologized about his comments admitting
that was him at his worst the two buried
the hatchet and Wendy went on later that
year to receive her walk of fame star
where she opened up to et about how she
overcame such a hectic career you have a
star on the Hollywood Walk of Fame I saw
the tears what does this mean to you
everything I mean it's it's a
culmination of over 30 years of being a
personality and you know it's not easy
being on TV for ten years by yourself
live and this has been a really hectic
year for me but also a hectic career you
know triumph over adversity stick to it
Wendy you'll show them you'll show them
and now it's my pleasure to show you
[Music]